la saga harry potter s'invite à
versailles une boutique spécialisée
s'est ouverte début février à côté du
vieux marché de la ville je vais ouvrir
les portes de cette mystérieuse
boutiques et j'espère que la magie va
opérer
[Musique]
je suis avec frédéric le gérant de cette
boutique alors frédéric pourquoi avoir
créé cet univers harry potter ici à
versailles alors tout d'abord c'est que
moi je suis déjà fan d'harry potter et
des animaux fantastiques et de l'auteure
jk rowling c'est compliqué pour les fans
de trouver en fait des objets au même
endroit donc pourquoi ne pas avoir créé
ma propre boutique et trouver mouvement
aussi du coup mes objets et propose aux
fans en fait de trouver les objets
d'harry potter au même endroit et pas
faire dix mille magasins ont commandé
dix fois sur internet
[Musique]
frédéric je vois que vous avez quelques
petites baguettes juste derrière vous
alors voilà est-ce que vous me
conseillez une baguette en particulier
alors à la base c'est la baguette qui
choisit son sorcier mais on va peut-être
tenté le coup avec une baguette de queen
is watching des animaux fantastiques
c'est un peu mou foldingue ou qu'une
petite femme un peu apprêtée chose comme
ça donc tu peux faire le geste ait pu
voir si quelque chose se saoulent sc le
sort c'est wingardium leviosa wingardium
leviosa wingardium leviosa pas les vieux
ça bon jouer j'ai tenté ça regarde youm
leviosa et bah non y'a rien qui s'est
soulevée donc effectivement c'est pas
forcément une baguette qui est fait pour
toi je suis juste un moldu pas forcément
on va voir si le choixpeau peut-être
décerner une maison d'un gris et une
cravate de chez poufsouffle on va
regarder avec le chapeau qui est juste
derrière moi alors le choixpeau et
choisit en fait la maison où tu vas
aller donc on va bien voir essayer
angers s'est dit voilà qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent à l'aï dit pas grand chose
donc peut-être qu'effectivement que tu
resteras un moldu oubliettes
merci de m'avoir fait réapparaître c'est
normal c'est normal oui mais alors
quelles sont les grandes dates à retenir
pour votre magasin alors on fait bien un
acteur le 27 mai prochain
mais pour l'instant on va juste né un
indice c'est que c'est un rouquin c'est
tout c'est tout pas n'ont pour l'instant
pas non non on attend ça avec impatience
en tout cas merci beaucoup